sommerzeit ist oldtimer zeigt die
beliebtheit alte autos hat den
deutschland seit 2008 deutlich
zugenommen und das merkt man auch im
oldtimer club rhein erft innerhalb von
neun jahren stieg die zahl der wagen mit
einem h-kennzeichen in ganz deutschland
um fast eine viertelmillion das heutige
treffen richtet sich aber nicht nur an
die oldtimer besitzer selbst sondern
wird zu einem familienausflug getreu dem
motto fahren mit freunden
[Musik]
aufbruchstimmung oldtimer nach oldtimer
rollt vom hof und macht sich auf den weg
zum gemeinsamen picknick zwischen rolls
royce bmw und mercedes gibt es auch so
manche raritäten zu bestaunen
so auch dieser porsche 356 speedster er
war das erste serienfahrzeug dass die
zuffenhausener hergestellt haben aber
nicht nur die seltenen autos glänzen
hier in der kolonne gibt es viele
fahrzeuge auf die sich am weg lohnt gar
der klub nicht markengebundenen ist
ergibt sich eine modellpalette die man
in dieser zusammenstellung nicht oft
sehen kann und fünf jahrzehnte der
automobilgeschichte waren hier durch
kleine dörfer und über landstraßen
[Musik]
bis die gesamte kolonne am ziel ankommt
hier dürfen wir ohnedies eine
verschnaufpause einlegen
fahrer und mitfahrer sorgen unterdessen
für ihr leibliches wohl
ob manfred püschel ist mit seinem rolls
royce silver cloud aus dem jahr 1962
dabei dass solche ausfahrten machen wir
zwei mal im jahr und das ist einfach
tradition
das schönste an solchen ausfahrten sieht
man gerade hinter mir das ist die
gemeinschaft man sie zusammen unterhält
sich man teilt das essen jeder bringt
etwas mit und man spricht über autos man
spricht über gott und die welt und das
baut einen auf wenn man vielleicht für
harte arbeitswoche hatte oder bei
anstrengende dienstreise oder das harte
rentnerleben auch dirk röttgen nimmt mit
seinem 50 jahre alten mercedes 250 sl an
der ausfahrt teil und genießt besonders
die gemeinsamen picknick
sind schon sehr wichtig weil die einfach
die gemeinschaft fördern dann im club
ich meine wir kennen uns ja alle mal
untereinander aber zu einem erlebnis die
vergisst man ja so schnell auch nicht
wir haben alle im tic würde ich mal so
sagen
und das sind oldtimer andere sammelt
uhren oder irgendwas anderes
ob sammelleidenschaft hobby oder
kindheitserinnerungen die liebe zu
oldtimern führt die unterschiedlichsten
menschen zusammen
bei den erwartungen an das treffen setzt
jeder andere schwerpunkte
ja zu hause ist das dann auch oft so
dass das verständnis nicht immer so da
ist wenn man so viel über die autos
quatschen und unter den club kameraden
kann es eigentlich nie genug sein von
daher da kann man sich gut austauschen
sagt moritz hat sich heute lieber zum
picknick fahren lassen und genießt das
zusammensein mit den anderen club
kameraden und vor allem auch deren
begleiterinnen
[Musik]
die leute zu essen und quatschen zu
können auch über andere themen frauen
letztlich geht es im oldtimer club rhein
erft einfach um das zusammenleben rund
um die alten schätze schließlich ist
regelmäßige bewegung ein muss
und vor allen dingen sie müssen auch mal
bewegt werden und dann kommen auch schon
mal was dran also nicht bewegt kommt
noch mehr dran denn da stehen sie sich
damit unserem holt thema club der bietet
auch die möglichkeit dass man leute
trifft die die gleichen probleme haben
und die lösungen wissen da findet man
hilfe der besitz eines oldtimers
bedeutet also viel mehr als nur ein
schönes auto sein eigen zu nennen
in einem oldtimer club wird man teil
einer gesellschaft und auch einer
kleinen oldtimer familie
[Musik]